vous êtes quelqu'un
d'intelligent de cultiver merci qui
connaît l'histoire sur lesquelles
vous savez vous savez où vous êtes et
vous savez vous êtes sur cette échiquier
si complexe qui est la politique
puisqu'il faut trouver sa place mais à
un moment donné pourquoi avoir accès
quasiment toute votre tout votre
discours tout votre campagne sur la
division
l'automobiliste en profite pour clamer
bien fort ce qu'il pense des forces de
l'ordre et de la justice
je suis monté les as à la mélodie tout à
l'heure jusqu'à 18 19 en octobre donc
après deux mois de campagne au moment où
j'ai parlé le plus librement
et uniquement de du Grand remplacement
et de l'islamisation du pays donc vous
voyez je suis monté très haut les
soirées
[Musique]
tout ça
oasis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les musulmans peuvent très bien avoir
une pratique de l'Islam compatible avec
la France c'est exactement ce que j'ai
dit dans le premier discours et je les
redis au Trocadéro dans un des derniers
discours de ma campagne donc je n'ai
jamais mis les musulmans tous dans le
même sac mais quand vous mettez l'islam
et l'islamisme dans le même sac déjà je
pense une erreur
[Rires]
et d'une pâte blanche
rien un peu je sais pas
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
vous avez dit j'ai gratté dans une fée
dans une cité avec une famille modeste
et c'était très dur de faire du partage
vis-à-vis de mes amis je ne voulais pas
qu'on me prenne pour un c'est
quelque chose qui m'aurait blessé
je peux comprendre que non mais
l'homosexualité c'est contre nature
nature insiste pour qu'il y en ait
beaucoup depuis le début que
aujourd'hui il y a plus de Gai que
d'ours polaires demain c'est le
printemps alors je suis allé voir un
petit peu ce qui se passait dans la
nature on va trouver une jeune fille qui
essaie de faire un qui utilise un
taille-haie tranquille sauf qu'il est
électrique donc ça c'est pas mal il y a
moins de bruit sur un taille électrique
mais par contre du bout de deux
donc si la nature t'intéresse oublie les
gays et sauve les ours mais sois
cohérents
si un de vos enfants est gays
aujourd'hui ça vous posera pas non ça me
pose pas
en même temps j'ai que des filles
[Applaudissements]
imagine maintenant paf on claque des
doigts il y a plus insta il y a plus Tik
Tok il y a plus snapchat il y a plus
youtube il y a plus twitch il y a plus
de réseau sociaux rien du tout vous
allez passer votre temps à faire quoi
comment vous allez vous occuper
il y a un piège non je vous souvenez que
Marie gentrique nous avait parlé de la
première version il y a maintenant deux
ou trois mois dans première édition on
en est maintenant à chat j'ai pété fort
la 4
E
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est peut-être grâce à Patrick que j'ai
fait de la télé et pourquoi
il lui a été proposé de faire cette
encore mieux l'après-midi qu'il a dit
non je vais être chanteur et qu'on lui a
dit bah là il y a un petit mec qui fait
les gadgets à Canal+ tu en penses quoi
il a regardé il a dit bon tu dois y
aller et c'est comme ça que je vais je
sais pas si on vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
de l'agression
alors normalement j'étais censé avoir un
gourdin ici mais Méline est délicatement
vu au nu me dire avant le début de
l'émission Bruno ton gourdin ne rentre
pas et on va rester sur cette Méline
Méline je te laisse volontiers pour
gourdin et on va se poser les 10
questions ça va frérot non attends t'as
pas le droit tu as pas le droit frère
parce que non non mais laissez laissé
mais juste personne peut venir comme ça
parle-moi après mon chéri parce que et
c'est le laisser le tranquille s'il vous
plaît ça c'est bon c'est bon 2 minutes
aucun problème mais là à l'antenne c'est
surtout en ce moment c'est c'est
compliqué je vais draguer
dragouiller je sens que je te dérange
non tu me dis pas mais merci quand même
très heureux de t'avoir connu salut toi
Dieu
merci mon capitaine Victoria abrit les
parties au Théâtre Antoine elle joue ce
soir elle a surtout vu Yoann Riu et
surtout elle a eu peur
danser elle s'est tiré
[Rires]
si tu vois le rendre là aussi tellement
beau moi j'ai enlèverai bien ça aussi
[Rires]
alors moi je vous demanderai pas
d'argent il y a une rumeur assez vite
qui dit que dans votre loge vous avez
vos propres toilettes privées que
personne les a jamais utilisé à part
vous jamais donc moi mon rêve
ultime c'est de monter sur votre trône
et de poser une pêche dans la bonne
humeur
[Applaudissements]
mais ça c'est pas une revendication